This summer, we're getting honest about summer blockbusters, past and present.
This is honest trailers, blockbuster summer
From Disney and the criterion collections.
Michael Bay comes the best title drop in a movie. Nick cage division.
Welcome to con air. I like to take his face. Oh,
welcome to the rock.
Hell yeah.
The rock Alcatraz has been captured by terrorists and
San Francisco is in the crosshairs.
Now the only way to stop a dangerously unstable chemical weapon is with a
chemically unstable dangerous man.
I said, I want to find some rockets.
Meet Stanley Goodspeed.
He's a scared little dork slash bad-ass adrenaline junkie slash Beatles
freak. Who's big one-liner is an Elton John song. You're the rocket,
but don't worry. This irrational character.
It makes perfect sense because he's being played by nineties, Nick cage.
What do.
You see? We cut the chit-chat a hall.
Although that's only because they couldn't get Arnold Schwartzenegger once that
makes even less sense.
In the name of Sue says hall.
How in the name of justice? Pothole. Yeah, just doesn't work to take the rock.
They need a man who knows it inside and out from it's mega man style fling traps
to the elaborate network of tunnels underneath,
which seems stupid at the time until he turned out to be real 20 years after the
movie came out, help will come in the form of Mason, John Mason,
a man who demands you shut up and listen while he's talking because he adds a sh
to every word of her. Magisters.
Retired.
Of course, together. They'll take on the robe general Frank Hummel,
a retired war hero who is getting way too nice for this.
You need to tell your teacher that you need to get back on the boat and go right
now. You're being detained against your will. For that. I apologize.
No one has to die here. I'm not ready to kill these people.
I'm not about to kill 80,000 innocent people. Do you think I'm out of my mind?
How did this kindly old man survive Vietnam and everyone supported by a boat's
worth of bad-ass character directors who get to look cool and say a couple of
lines.
What do you have a water pistol? You know, God well,
I can't get my money.
These guys, these are my Avengers right here.
Get ready for Michael Bay to turn the Bay area into the Bay area with
his signature explosions,
us military fetish and love of wheelchair athletes. Huh?
Never knows that one before,
because this movie about a chemical nerd and an old spy saving the day doesn't
even start until after a whole other action movie about them teaming up in a
film with so many well-directed action scenes you'll dare to ask,
is this what a good Michael Bay movie looks like? And to that we say yes,
come to think of it. All a base best of is rock based.
Oh, Oh, I got my toe.
Can they reattach it? So to a little bit better than your best.
Losers, always whine about their best winners go home.
And the prom queen.
For an on-screen cluster that was only matched by the one going on off screen
with Sorkin and Tarantino being brought in for rewrites.
Co-producers ODing on cocaine during production and Bay walking off his
own movie until they agreed to spend millions on a 32nd underwater.
See basically this moment, but cool.
Um, I take, I try to take people on an emotional ride and um,
excuse me. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Okay.
Story. We have no choice,
but to Stanley double load seven general grievance
Navy who can take a nerve gas during your face to
guru. Oh, the city ransom for a million bucks or to the Candyman GaN.
What a Cox. Jonathan Ben, Wes
ball and gentlemen.
Gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen.
Welcome to the rock gentlemen. Dwayne Johnson.
Hey fellas. If your girl asks you to communicate more in the bedroom,
this is not what they mean.
That's interesting. It's very compelling cream,
peach sorbet persuasion.
Hey, screen junkies, check out this Q and a with Janet.
Borney the voice of Cora from avatar legend of Korra in our series. Hey fandom,
where the people who make your favorite movies, TV, and games,
answer your questions. Click the link in the description below the devil,
went down to Georgia, looking for a soul to steal.